côté terrain michel platini a dévoilé le
logo de la coupe du monde de football 98
qui aura lieu vous le savez en france
le ballon est un soleil une façon de
dire que le football est universel
françois brabant et et didier da en 1998
les français ont eu peur de s'ennuyer
alors ils sont créés à l'image du soleil
et ils sont imaginé un jeu
la cokerie
en 1998 s'élèvera en france beausoleil
le football
france 98
c'est donc le soleil français qui sera
chargée d' illuminé le monde du football
à l'aube du troisième millénaire mais
pour que ce soleil la bri vraiment de
mille feux il faut tout d'abord je
voulais venir
oui monsieur rené schmitt qui parlait
pour le renom du pronom 1002 du ministre
des sports nous a dit que la décision
serait imminente et que le grand stade
sera choisi dans les jours qui viennent
je pense mais la construction du grand
stade n'est pas encore commencée que les
français ont déjà un autre défi à
relever la fifa représenter ce matin par
sepp blatter est revenu très satisfaite
de sa world cup américaine
il va falloir faire aussi bien oh non je
pense qu'on pourra faire beaucoup mieux
je plaisante mais disons qu'on pourra
pas faire aussi bien que dans le
remplissage des stades parce que nous
avons pas d stade de 80000 euros non 70
aux etats unis 17 de quatre années parce
qu'on ne l'a pas encore d'envoyer dans
ces difficiles après d'autre part la
coupe du monde aux états unis ça a été
une coupe du monde coca cola nous
faisons champagne
bon résumons on a le logo on a l'esprit
on va bientôt avoir le stade
on va aussi connaître les villes reste à
trouver le joueur qui la brandir à cette
coupe en 98 trois mois après la pose de
la première pierre le grand stade où se
déroulera le 12 juillet 98 la finale de
la coupe du monde de foot bal a enfin
trouvé son nom le stade de france les
concessionnaires souhaité une
appellation style élise homme qui parle
aux étrangers les puristes souhaité le
baptiser du nom d'un sportif comme jules
rimet le fondateur français de la coupe
du monde
finalement vous le voyez décision mi
chèvre mi chou reportage laurent
fabrique ball et claude sicard le jour
se lève sur le chantier de ce qu'on
appelle encore le grand stade
un jour pas comme les autres un jour de
baptême certes la maison de la radio n'a
rien d'une cathédrale et ces messieurs
ne sont pas des hommes d'église
il n'empêche qu'on est vraiment là pour
baptiser un bébé dans la recherche du
nom a nécessité des mois de réflexion et
la mise en place d'un comité
13h15 fin du suspense le 2 juillet 1998
la finale de la coupe du monde de
football aura lieu au stade de france
et bien voilà c'était pas compliqué
stade de france juste le choix le plus
consensuel est le moins risqué
j'espérais que la seconde réunion à
paraître est peut-être des termes plus
novateurs faut bien le reconnaître là
dessus j'ai plutôt échoué c'est pas
original mais c'est un nom qui va rester
dans l'histoire et qui est très beau me
suis ravi de
dysphasie non parce que il aura donc
fallu deux réunions du comité de
réflexion et une consultation populaire
sur les ondes de france pour en arriver
là le stade de france qui en tout cas ne
sera pas que les stades du football
tourné cousin germain aurait mieux
football simplement je crois qu'on a une
chance extraordinaire c'est que le rugby
va finalement inauguré ce grand stade
avant la coupe du monde de football en
tout cas l'équipe de france est prête
elle sera au rendez vous ce sera pour le
tournoi des cinq nations 1998 si le
chantier avance comme prévu
puis il y aura donc la coupe du monde et
d'éventuels jeux olympiques le grand
stade a désormais un nom il reste à lui
construire un destin
vous êtes allé voir aimé jacquet à trois
jours de france turquie qui est comme
l'équipe de france dans une période un
peu délicate jusqu'à la coupe du monde
voilà aimé jacquet en profite pour
rappeler devant revault le gardien c'est
nouveau aussi il y à leur tour de gava
et puis donc candela et goma alors
évidemment france turquie on pourrait
croire que le football français est en
sommeil après l'euro et puis à deux ans
des coupes du monde vient paradoxalement
c'est là qu'ils aimé jacquet prend son
pied figurez vous pourquoi bien parce
que aimé jodar son assistant de l'elysée
c'est à partir de maintenant qu'on peut
construire mettre en place quelque chose
et son véritable travail d'entraîneur
c'est maintenant parce que quand tu as
convient de son est arrivé on le sait eh
bien on gère le quotidien on peut pas
toujours faire grand chose
regardez écoutez mes jacques et surtout
sur son plan de bataille pour la coupe
du monde
aimé jacquet est heureux il plaisante
avec la presse la coupe du monde en
france après tout c'est dans deux ans
seulement il n'y a pas la pression de la
qualification et pourtant il faut faire
comprendre à tous joueurs médias publics
qu il se passe toujours quelque chose
dans l'équipe de france et que c'est
contre la turquie c'est à dire
maintenant que son plan de conquête de
la coupe du monde commence et c'est
innovation tenter quelque chose sans
détruire ce qu'on a ce qu'on a construit
pour celle qui est difficile et à partir
du tournoi de france
une base nouvelle et on recommence je
dirais le sprint pour allez aborder la
coupe du monde
problème numéro un comment surveiller
l'évolution de tous les tricolores
partir à l'étranger espagne italie
angleterre allemagne avait on a des
joueurs qui sont d'allemagne pour
l'oublier aussi et bien nous essayons de
répartir le travail en changeant chaque
fois nos observations
c'est à dire que c'est un recoupement
d'observation qui me permet à près de
faire la synthèse aimer le football
français ne résisterait pas à une
deuxième vague de départs vers
l'étranger l'équipe de france va t-elle
en souffrir je ne crois pas parce que
nous on a vis-à-vis de beaucoup de
football une une avancée exceptionnelle
ses coûts on a mis en place la formation
une formation qui a été tant décrié
rappelez-vous mon dieu qu'est-ce que
j'ai pas entendu puis maintenant subite
non les mêmes répète mais la formation
heureusement problème on le soler si le
football avait pas eu cette formation
peut-être qu'il irait plus de football
français à l'heure actuelle problème
numéro 2 les bons attaquants sont rares
en plus dugarry ou et des quais murray
sont blessés l'offensive est bien le
souci d'aimé jacquet nous on veut des
garçons qui kayl qui qui qui qui ont
envie d'aller la surface de vérité
et ça il faut les former c'est un mental
est là nous ne sommes penchés là dessus
mais aussi il faut peut-être peut-être
un petit peu patient parce que nous n'a
pas on a par moments des attitudes qui
sont complètement de contradictoire
il faut quand même être un petit peu
patient le poste est tellement tellement
dur et bien il faut être là dessus
peluches peut-être les entourer de d'une
communication spéciale on a montré nos
limites à l'euro maintenant on va
aborder la coupe du monde c'est un autre
événement c'est d'autres équipes c'est
tout des équipes sud américaines qui ont
de la qualité l'argentine le brésil la
colombie
donc vous voyez c'est un autre challenge
donc on est très conscient qu'on a
encore beaucoup de choses à faire et
beaucoup de progression a réalisé
beaucoup de joueurs en europe des
calendriers parfois trop chargé et des
matches amicaux pour travailler aimé
jacquet l'a dit tout de suite j'ai une
situation sportive délicate à gérer
28 - 6,6 footballeurs ont quitté le
groupe france
on connaît désormais le nom des heureux
sélectionnés pour le mondial
mais jacquet a mis fin au suspense dans
la matinée jean philippe guillin marc
felix 11h45 ce matin et me jacques et
met fin à un long suspense et confirme
ce que les sélectionnés français savait
depuis hier soir de 28
la liste des joueurs est enfin ramené à
22 non c'est un choix et élimine un
gardien les tizi et cinq joueurs de
champ l'aigle chetout lamouchi en bas et
anelka bien sûr que une décision et 17
c'est dur c'est même très cruel mais
nous vivons dans un monde cruel
donc à partir de là et il faut en
accepter ou faut faire autre chose même
s'ils ne l'avouent pas tous clairement
les joueurs semblent soulagés et
respecte le choix de l'entraîneur j'ai
pas à juger de la manière j'ai pas à
juger du choix simplement il est clair
que quelle que soit la manière quel que
soit le choix
ça fait toujours des malheurs durée des
inquiétudes on était un groupe de 28 je
pense 28 bons joueurs donc on pouvait
s'attendre
ça fait partie du métier je pouvais
faire partie des six bien sûr d'autres
comme zidane deschamps karembeu
djorkaeff était sûr d'être du voyage et
pouvait dormir sur leurs deux oreilles
même ceux qui sont partis ils ont prouvé
qu'ils pouvaient faire partie de
l'équipe de france donc c'est pour ça
que c'est bien c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
partis par la grande porte pas bar
petite porte
voilà donc la fameuse liste tant
attendue
elle allie expérience et jeunesse 12 des
joueurs convoqués étaient déjà présents
lors du championnat d'europe en
angleterre
en 1996 le groupe définitif s'envole
lundi pour casablanca au programme deux
rencontres amicales contre la belgique
et le maroc au passage dugarry et henry
qui font un peu figure de repêcher de la
dernière heure pourront peut être prouvé
que le maillot tricolore les inspire
dans vingt jours
la france débute en coupe du monde face
à l'afrique du sud la stratégie des
bleus après les dernières nouvelles
plutôt rassurantes pour zinédine zidane
aimé jacquet a mis sur pied un véritable
plan de bataille à un camp français qui
se veut très confiant reportage de
dominique sopo et gilles jacquier dans
les sous-bois de clairefontaine aimé
jacquet a le sourire il a retrouvé tout
son monde
zidane sourit aussi pas de problème les
tests du matin sont rassurants il est
bon pour le service
je serai prêt jeu de toute façon je sais
pas c'est pas une cheville qui m'aura
mettait je crois que j'aurais tout fait
pour pour être présents coquilles à
présent sur le terrain présent devant le
but marqué au mieux pour le plaisir
c'était le but du jeu aujourd'hui
histoire de re créer de bonnes habitudes
ou peut-être de réveiller des vocations
dormi belle occasion de travailler un
peu plus les coups de pied arrêtés
c'est évident que beaucoup de matchs se
régleront sur les coups de pied arrêtés
parce que les équipes ont été très
proches les unes des autres
donc nous on a un gros potentiel l'un
des joueurs de grande taille
on a des bons tireurs des bons centreurs
donc à partir de là on doit profiter des
matches serrés qui bascule sur un coup
de pied
voilà la rançon du haut niveau et dans
le huis clos de l'entraînement du soir
c'est la tactique que l'on peaufine à
l'abri des regards
je pense que ça va être notre force et
si si si on résume bien notre coup je
peux vous garantir que ce sera une
grande réussite pour nous dans cette
partie d'échecs qui se prépare le jeudi
trouve pas toujours se rend compte
ne dit on pas aujourd'hui les matches se
gagnent beaucoup avec le physique
beaucoup aussi avec la tactique et à
l'occasion seulement avec un peu de
football
à l'heure des choix d'avant-match ce
supporters opté pour le match nul à
l'heure des spectacles d'ouverture le
stade de france n'a pas eu ses géants
mais simplement une cérémonie de mise en
forme ronde si possible carette pelouse
pour ces rase-mottes le tapis vert entre
dans la danse en 380 morceaux pour
commencer des petit bout de jardin pour
footballeur en herbe qui laissons la
place à celle ans bête vos rebond
capricieux
[Musique]
et puis le ballon reprendra ses droits
sortis d'une fleur le football commence
sérieusement à prendre sa place dans le
tapage et la percussion de supporters
ars aux couleurs des 32 pays
participants
[Musique]
enfin les ballons prennent possession du
ciel quelques minutes avant que les
joueurs occupent le terrain le reste
sera protocolaire l'ouverture de la 16e
coupe du monde c'est déjà du passé
ap
un jour
attention
marquer
ado
l'équipe de france elle est arrivée
aujourd'hui dans sa retraite près
d'aix-en-provence celle là même qui lui
avait porté bonheur en 1984 à la veille
de la demi-finale du championnat
d'europe qu'elle veut gagner les joueurs
français est invisible aujourd'hui
s'entraînait à huit clos retour donc sur
ces dernières 48 heures pour prendre la
température du moral et de la forme de
notre onze tricolore yann lavoix andré
germain les bleus n'auront sans doute
pas le loisir ni le temps de taper la
petite balle pourtant depuis ce matin
jacques et ses boys sont logés ici au
moulin de verneuil à côté de salon de
provence
c'est dans ce havre de verdure de
fraîcheur et de calme qu'ils vont
préparer leur entrée dans la coupe du
monde à l'abri du chahut et des
attroupements que suscite leur venue
dans la région
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je peux pas mieux espérer pour un
problème là dessus pour un match des
verts fera pas d'ouverture mais pour la
première de coupe du roi on sait c'est
fabuleux
le minot du quartier de la castellane
avait déjà donné rendez-vous à sa
famille à ses amis aux français ici même
au vélodrome il ya quelques mois
face à la norvège alors à 24 heures du
match la motivation est telle que les
mots lui manquent pour l'exprimer
je plains pas je peux même pas dire ce
que je ressens quoi tellement c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les bleus comptent sur les soixante
mille supporters du vélodrome demain et
les anciens joueurs marseillais
s'attendent à de chaleureuses
retrouvailles gens adorent le football
ils viennent au stade pour voir du beau
football mais savons reconnaître aussi
les les qualités de battant d'un joueur
dans moi j'ai été très bien acceptée je
garde que de bons souvenirs de mon
passage à marseille
[Musique]
l'afrique du sud peut être l'unique bon
souvenir de guivarc'h avec l'équipe de
france il avait en effet inscrit il ya
huit mois contre elle son seul but à ce
jour avec les bleus alors l'afrique du
sud c'est lui qui en parle le mieux
on les a vus un peu hier c'est à la télé
notamment les matches amicaux qu'ils ont
disputés ils ont un gros potentiel
physique des joueurs athlétiques donc à
nous d'essayer de bien les contourner
ces duels qui vont faire la différence
grande confiance en nous grande
confiance
un homme également n'a forcément pas
laisser passer cette joie immense qui
était la sienne il s'agit d'aimé jacquet
le sélectionneur
à mon avis il s'est fait beaucoup de
soucis pendant le match ce soir il est
soulagé nous l'écoutons dominique
champeaux a réussi à le rencontrer juste
à la sortie du match
c'est une belle qualification elle est à
mon avis mérité par le jeu que nous
avons déployés surtout dans la halle
dans la phase je dirais du match où
l'équipe de france a été extrêmement
conquérante
malheureusement on n'a pas su
concrétiser toutes nos belles situations
offensives
on a vu une équipe de france en première
mi-temps très maîtresse d'elle-même
frais maîtresses dray s'en sortent très
dominatrice en deuxième mi temps ça
commençait un petit peu la fatigue
commence à se faire sentir non c'est
surtout que lorsqu'on change le
dispositif
on s'est un petit peu affaibli tout à
fait normalement mais il fallait bien
faire quelque chose moi je ne voulais
pas arriver à aux prolongations donc
encore moins au coup de pied au but
bon ben la décision s'est pas trop mal
tourné pour nous et heureusement on vous
a vu beaucoup moins expansif que contre
le paraguay
non parce que là
dans un an un mage ce type là nous
savons les forces qui est qu'ils sont
contre nous et là il faut être toujours
en réflexion pour apporter quelques
petites retouches à aller qui pour lui
donner une bouffée d'oxygène donc il
faut rester lucide contre le paraguay on
a écrasé cette équipe donc c'était parce
que je dirais une injustice que le voir
que cette équipe de france n'avait pas
marqué de but l'a conduit l'équipe
italienne il faut faire très attention
ce sont des maîtres dans et qui sont qui
sont des maîtres dans l'art de prendre
en contre je sais que c'est un match que
vous tenez absolument à gagner parce que
c'était le match de référence pour cette
équipe
oui mais on a bien fait dans son contenu
je pense que la qualification s'est
faite aux coups de pied au but mais elle
aurait pu se faire normalement tard par
un but ou par une situation beaucoup
plus favorable pour l'équipe de france
on peut dire ce soir sur ce qu'on a vu
de ce match que l'équipe de france peut
aller au bout
les vallées au bout mais valéo bout
c'est obligé tellement qu'il y ait de la
fois dense dans cette équipe il ya un
groupe qui qui est fabuleux qui a envie
de réussir quelque chose l'a vu encore
même dans les prolongations où on a eu
cette équipe de france qui tentait tout
qu'ils essayaient de bousculer cette
défense de fer et italiennes merci aimé
jacquet l'équipe de france reprendra
tout de suite la route de clairefontaine
ou quatre jours ne seront pas de trop
pour préparer ces demi finales que l'on
attend évidemment avec impatience
mais tout d'abord on va souligné cet
engouement assez inhabituel finalement
2-2 tout un pays pour une couleur pour
le bleu ce maillot bleu qui aurait
peut-être été un petit peu allez on va
dire un gars dans les rues il y a
quelques mois mais aujourd'hui c'est à
la mode c'est très tendance comme on dit
c'est la meilleure manière que nous
raconte christelle bertrand avec laurent
hamida non seulement ces femmes-là
supporter leur mari mais pour la
première fois elles portent leur maillot
elle montre l'exemple soutiennent
l'équipe de france comme des milliers
d'autres failles plus les joueurs
tricolores passent les tours plus les
maillots se vend y en aura pas pour tout
le monde
longtemps qu'adidas france on n'avait
pas effectivement largement misé sur le
maillot de l'équipe de france là on va
être un peu juste juste dans le nombre
est juste dans les tailles les magasins
sont proches de la rupture de stock
on veut aussi être beau avec ce maillot
mais c'est dur d'en trouver un qui vous
va comme un gant
je voudrais porter le maillot des pieds
de prince pour voir d'un coquet l'équipe
quelle équipe le supporte
malheureusement ils sont très difficiles
à obtenir il n'est pas sur les
champs-elysées
demain je vois que grande taille manque
le maillot bleu blanc rouge est aussi
devenu un souvenir pour les supporters
étrangers
meilleure vente dans le magasin le match
zidane ronaldo est lancé à 350 francs le
tee shirt
les ventes ont quand même augmenté de
40% le rayon maillot se vide
si la france est en finale on va finir
par acheter son maillot sous le menton
on peut aussi fabriquer sa propre tenue
les stylistes supporters ne sont jamais
à court d'imagination
il y en a même que ça fait pas mal
travailler du chapeau
le maillot est à la mode normal c'est
l'été c'est la coupe du monde
dans ce cas là la meilleure tenue c'est
le maillot de bain
surprise de ce mondial dans les mois qui
ont précédé les allergiques au football
nous avait prédit une augmentation des
scènes de ménage voir des divorces
pendant la compétition et bien on s'est
aperçu que parmi les téléspectateurs de
la coupe du monde il y avait plus de 30%
de femmes
à commencer bien entendu par les
premiers intéressés les épouses
respectives des joueurs de l'équipe de
france sophie mais elle
jean-paul chausset petite ambiance en
cette fin d'après midi devant le siège
de la fédération française de football
avenue d'iéna à paris une poignée de
supporteurs qui semble égarée
et pourtant non ceux là savent que c'est
ici comme avant chaque match que les
femmes et fiancée de joueurs se donnent
rendez-vous pour partir ensemble au
stade de france acclamer leurs héros
frédéric dugarry vania lama et claude
deschamps respecte le mot d'ordre de la
fédération
la discrétion pas un mot ne filtre de ce
côté là bonjour bonjour vous allez bien
alors comment ça va ça va bien
al'approche la limmat vous en avez
combien prime
mais bah on commence à subir les pisans
que la pression mais ça va aller
notre marié telefonica est arrivé là il
a la pression sur forcément mais ça va
et
ça ne dit pas vous avez votre mari au
téléphone
oui ça se passe bien ça a l'air est ce
que vous l'avez souhaité la bon courage
j'avais des grigris il a quelque chose à
vous sur lui pendant le mode quelques
jolis
non je pense qu'il donnera le droit
c'est de sa fille poignet au poignet
éventuellement poser une question mise
42e adriana est aussi connu pour son
record personnel une longueur de jean
faramineuses un maître 24 c'est toujours
le même rituel vous savez moi je lui
souhaite bonne chance et lui il me
répond tout va bien on va gagner ce soir
après le match
on leur a tout promis quelques
précieuses minutes d'intimité avec leurs
hommes
cette solide et devrait amener ces
messieurs souhaitons le à se dépasser
en marge de la compétition sportive le
mondial a engendré une autre forme de
compétition plus feutrée celle là entre
le premier ministre et le président de
la république qui depuis le début du
mois de juin soit dit respectueusement
se marquent à la culotte comme disent
les spécialistes damien thévenot vincent
fourcade coup de sifflet final hier soir
ni bleus l'emportent
l'entraîneur aimé jacquet il soulagé
jacques chirac exulte c'est vraiment
l'un des plus beaux jours de l'as v
sport français une belle histoire qui
démarre sur la pelouse de clairefontaine
les bleus s'entraînent mondial n'a pas
encore commencé mais déjà le président
chirac occupe le terrain sur l'ailé
gauche
la réaction est immédiate le gardien de
la majorité reprend la balle au bond
confidence j'ai commencé ma carrière
sportive comme ball effectivement avant
de passer au basket
arrêtez les buts comme barthez les uns
l'ont fait les autres en rêve
oui la france bat le danemark qui va
rencontrer l'italie en quart de finale
en voyage officiel à sienne le premier
ministre joue au tokyo avec son
homologue italien
mais à l'autre bout du monde au
mozambique jacques chirac a déjà montré
qu'il est le premier les supporters je
suis le plus heureux des hommes
et j'ai reçu des félicitations qui m'ont
touché droite au coeur de la part du
président chissano
je l'en remercie encore
la france bat l'italie aux tirs au but
forcément un tel exploit s'apprête à la
métaphore je suis un entraîneur joueur
dit et l'ange de jacquet et de zidane
un président et un premier ministre qui
ne seront pas les derniers à célébrer la
victoire de la france si tout se passe
bien dimanche soir madame monsieur
bonsoir la france ceux touchés par la
grâce du football traverse est elle une
phase d'euphorie une étrange fièvre
disent les sociologues fait d'un
sentiment national joyeux et
multiraciale les centaines de milliers
de supporteurs qui célébrait mercredi
soir au delà de tous les clivages
sociaux
la victoire des tricolores donne la
mesure de cet enthousiasme communicatif
et voilà que maintenant l'assemblée
nationale porte sur sa façade les
couleurs de la france en finale
sébastien guibert à la location
la cérémonie se veut solennel un grand
cri du coeur s'est affiché ce matin sur
un mur de l'assemblée nationale allez
les bleus allez la france
encouragements symbolique à l'heure où
la nation vie pour certains des jours
historiques
quand la france se rassemblent elle peut
gagner et que quand elle gagne elle et
rassemble et ça c'est extrêmement rare
car il flotte dans l'air comme un
étrange parfum d'ivresse immense bonheur
collectif et spontané qui ne comble pas
uniquement les supporters de la première
heure la demi finale france croatie par
exemple a fait vibrer plus de 20
millions de téléspectateurs parmi eux la
moitié pratiquement étaient des femmes
cette coupe du monde se savoure donc en
famille entre amis parmi une foule
d'inconnus autour d'un drapeau tricolore
devenu emblème de fierté étendard
d'euphorie qu'est la vraie le sentiment
d'appartenance est un pays bas et tous
ensemble alors qu'on a cherché à diviser
à lescure certains à pleurer de bonheur
très bonne nouvelle politique la cote de
popularité du président de la république
et du premier ministre n'ont d'ailleurs
jamais été aussi élevée dans les
sondages popularité et reconnaissance
voilà bien ce qu inspire aussi l'équipe
de france
acclamé à son retour mercredi soir à
clairefontaine des joueurs de football
perçus comme des symboles nationaux de
vaillance et d' enthousiasme
au lendemain de france-croatie philippe
rossi vendeurs de drapeaux a vu défiler
dans sa paisible boutique des dizaines
de supporteurs le bleu blanc rouge se
vend à merveille entre 30 et 600 francs
pièce pour l'emblème de la fierté
l'étendard de l'euphorie depuis la
demi-finale en effet on est impatient de
les envoyer pour avant ils croient trop
maintenant presque
et ça marche très bien depuis une
journée je rêve les français se découvre
depuis surtout la qualification contre
l'italie
farouchement supporters d'une équipe
parée de toutes les vertus combatives
généreuse victorieuse la liesse dans les
rues de paris et de la france entière
réunit les supporters comblés femmes
enfants jeunes plongés dans un grand
moment de bonheur et devant l'assemblée
que madame la ministre de l'emploi de la
solidarité m'a suggéré de lever cette
séance sur une ola même les élus du
peuple cède à l'engouement national
le ton est feutrée la cérémonie
protocolaire et le propos grave c'est
que leur est historique
quand la france se rassemblent elle peut
gagner
et que quand elle gagne elle et
rassemble et ça c'est extrêmement
on peut adhérer à l'équipe de france
mais on peut à dire l équipe de france
pour des raisons totalement différentes
si bien qu'il n'ya pas d'homogénéisation
des catégories sociales et les classes
sociales qui adhèrent à qui soutiennent
l'équipe de france en fait
il ya une totale diversité des points de
vue sur cette équipe et des raisons pour
laquelle on adhère la coupe du monde se
révèle être bien plus qu'une simple
compétition sportive un étrange moment
d'unité politique et nationale
le président de la république et le
premier ministre n'ont d'ailleurs jamais
été aussi haut dans les sondages
la france en bleu tout le pays retient
son souffle à 24 heures d'une finale de
rêve france brésil
aujourd'hui c'était le moment ou jamais
de s'offrir le maillot de l'équipe de
france tenus indispensable pour tous
supporters des bleus certains magasins
ont vendu jusqu'à 150 maillot par jour
et toutes les boutiques ou presque sont
en rupture de stock reportage de peggy
le roy et jacques gauthier footix peu
s'époumonait la vedette des rayons ce
n'est pas lui mais le maillot des bleus
sur les champs elysées le magasin de la
coupe a été livrée ce matin à midi il
est en rupture de stock
je parle a dû en avoir une deux cents à
près de 150 et voilà le reste est pas
une vingtaine et une trentaine
grosse bataille grosse bataille même
combat dans les magasins de sport ils
trouvaient ça taille parmi les derniers
maillots bleus relève de l'exploit
aujourd'hui la tenue de l'équipe de
france s'élève à 400 francs environ
demain elle pourrait devenir un
collector le fournisseur arrête la
fabrication ce soir médaillés maillot
que j'ai eues en grande taille ont été
vendus avant d'arriver en mélodies
s'étaient réservés
ceux qui sont là sont pas réservés non
c'est petite thaïs et c'est là dessus
que j'avais le plus de stock et là bon
je pense que ce soit je croyais qu
laissé loin derrière les couleurs
brésiliennes au début du mondial le bleu
a finalement trouvé le chemin des
caisses les ventes ont décollé juste
après les quarts de finale le premier
grand succès des hommes d'aimé jacquet
des victoires sur lesquels ni le
fournisseur ni les grands magasins
n'aurait parié
très honnêtement on n'avait pas prévu
cet engouement sur les produits coupe du
monde
on était côte est un peu dépassé par les
événements mais on ne pense pas non plus
que la france irait si loin
dimanche soir la vague bleue pourrait
peut-être chez ces les désormais
célèbres costard cravate
la surprise de ce mondial aura été sans
conteste l'engouement des femmes
françaises on les disait anti foot et
pourtant elles se sont convertis au
point de devenir de véritables
supporteurs à l'image de ces femmes
d'amérique du sud ou du nord de l'europe
christelle bertrand dominique merlin en
france les femmes il football n'ont
jamais fait bon ménage
le mondial a donné un bon coup de balai
aux idées reçues trois mois avant le
premier match
70 % n'en avait rien à faire mais la
france gagne alors un gradin comme un
ministre ça peut être aussi féminin elle
est indifférente en fait aux sports en
tant que tel mais finalement elle
n'était pas indifférente à l'événement
mondial spectaculaire l intensité
émotionnelle et dramatique qui est en
train de se jouer et comme en train de
vivre la coupe du monde c'est la grande
saga de l'été le casting le scénario
tout est là pour faire un succès des
rebondissements des épisodes français
ont été suivis à 50% par des femmes même
sans avoir téléviseur j'ai vibré quand
même jusqu'au dernier moment la cause
par exaspérer les croisés vont être
renvoyées devant la télé a été installée
et à force de se faire mousser le
football est le sujet de prédilection
dans le dernier salon où l'on cause
au départ on s'est dit bon est clair que
les gens on n'aura pas beaucoup donnent
durant le match plus de femmes et est en
fait les femmes assistaient pour
regarder le match est alors qu'on
pensait pas du tout ça les intéresse le
grand bleu a déteint sur un public
inattendu
le mondial c'est la dernière coupe à la
mode les françaises se sont piqués au
jeu et aux joueurs
martin deschamps et laurent blanc didier
joker thuram
alors attention si on gagne ça va friser
l'hystérie pas de but pas de victoire
sans le soutien inconditionnel des
supporters derrière leurs équipes venues
du monde entier ils ont animé les stades
où les champs elysées encore images
souvenirs de ses supporters sélectionnés
par daïc audouit
[Musique]
m
je peux voir
[Applaudissements]
ils sont ici
c'est pendant un mois paris a accueilli
le monde
je l'avais bien commencé les
chippendales écossais déferlé sur la
capitale
la tartan army mêler ses couleurs aux
jaune et vert du brésil
le parc des princes et le stade de
france pour fait le plein de spectateurs
mais dans les rues de paris il n'eut pas
l'ambiance souhaitée on s'attendait à
une vague de supporters ce fut juste une
écume la faute au match par crier dans
toute la france les supporters ne sont
que de passage
aussi pas de temps à perdre une seule
destination pour tous les champs elysées
avec à chaque fois des scènes de
fraternisation habituels dans la région
il n'y a pas eu de problèmes de violence
au hit parade des images souvenirs
les supporters écossais les meilleurs du
monde et les nigérians qui avant pendant
et après le match n'arrête pas de danse
et une chorégraphie qui n'égale pas
celle du supporters chiliens obtenant un
billet mais en fait il faut attendre la
victoire française en quarts et demi
finales pour que la folie s'installe
vraiment à paris les images que l'on
espère voir encore ce soir même en cas
de défaite
vous le disais en début de cette édition
spéciale
un million et demi de personnes sur les
champs elysées la nuit dernière à paris
on n'avait jamais vu ça
le plus simple pour le résumé c'est de
parler d'une marée bleu blanc rouge
commenté olivier caroff du jamais vu
depuis bientôt un demi siècle paris qui
exulte paris qui tient ses libérateurs
un million et demi de personnes sur les
champs elysées une nuit blanche pour
voir la vie en bleu
[Applaudissements]
et dans cette marée humaine un
déferlement de bonheur légumes d'un rêve
qui enfant s'est réalisé
camara
m
c'est de la pure folie la règle c'est de
la pure folie je ne connais pas tout le
monde sait tout le monde il est beau et
pour tout le monde les mêmes héros cette
équipe de france où chacun peut trouver
son idole il est humain pas plaint que
nous il est 12 d' de béjaïa algérie on
mettrait quand on est venu ici en france
pour supporter l'équipe euros
et c'est passé
[Applaudissements]
et pour tous la même bannière tricolore
jusque tôt ce matin dix prix unique de
cette coupe du monde a coulé dans les
artères de la capitale
et le match à peine terminée des
centaines et des centaines de milliers
de supporters ont envahi les champs
elysées une fête comme la france n'en
avait pas connu ditto depuis la
libération
une communion totale de tout un peuple
olivier caroff ead petula jamais l'arc
de triomphe n'aura si bien porté son nom
sous l'oeil des géants de l'équipe de
france
un million et demi de personnes hier
soir sur les champs elysées toute une
nuit blanche pour voir la vie en bleu
[Applaudissements]
le rêve est devenu réalité et les
brésiliens qui savent l'effet que ça
fait les ont accompagnés
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
pour danser on a même trouvé mieux que
la samba
une telle marée humaine c'était du
jamais vu depuis près d'un demi-siècle
le même drapeau pour tous et à chacun
son héros
faut pas qu'il oublie que ces deux faits
majeurs
de toute façon personne n'a été oublié
même pas la mascotte surtout pas
l'entraîneur mais dès les premières
minutes de fait paris s'était déjà
choisi un libérateur tout de suite
retour à la liesse cet après midi sur
les champs elysées avec la remontée des
joueurs de l'équipe de france après
avoir déjeuné avenue d'iéna au siège de
la fédération française de football ils
sont montés dans un bus découvert à
plateforme pour remonter les champs
elysées présentation sous forme de clips
peggy leroy et jean laurent serra
[Applaudissements]
au bâlois
m
ouais
ce n'est pas là
ol
[Applaudissements]
on a déniché un staff à rennes il ya
aucune référence
le pape n'est rien à côté ça fait
soixante quatre ans que les français
attendent d'être au final on n'est plus
à une heure près c'est la première coupe
du monde fou qui fait ça aussi
ils doivent passer ils vont passer c'est
sûr pourquoi ils passeraient pas s'il me
fait pas peur comme ça
oui
les
hello
oui
et
m
[Applaudissements]
la journée des bleus yann lavoix vous le
disais tout à l'heure est loin d'être
terminée elle avait commencé ce matin
dès la sortie du centre mitic de
clairefontaine la retraite des bleus
là où se sont succédé les entraînements
et les périodes de repos et celle
bertrand et laurent hamida ont suivi
l'équipe de france toute cette journée
si vous voulez savoir où se trouve
l'équipe de france
vous n'avez qu'à suivre les banderoles
[Musique]
ce matin elle a commencé par la
fédération française de football les
traits sont un peu tirés le sommeil ils
y penseront plus tard j'ai fait j'ai
fait la fête avec eux
avec mes amis à l'hôtel la folie était à
clairefontaine fiers comme des champions
du monde ils chérissent leur couper la
partage avec le public
la fête a commencé dans le car 70
kilomètres d'échauffement avant le
bouquet final
zidane est passé de meneur de jeu à
meneur de revue
sur le chemin même les feux rouge vire
au bleu
les supporters veulent montrer leur
amour les joueurs leur ont donné tant de
bonheur des milliers de personnes
ouvrent la route aux champions du monde
on se croirait sur une étape du tour de
france acclamé les joueurs font un
dernier petit coucou avant d'aller
dormir un peu certains n'ont pas dormi
du tout sous la pluie ils ont attendu 10
heures ce matin pour voir passer
l'équipe dans l'autre sens une dernière
fois
mais la fête n'est pas finie on
essaierait l'apprécier du mieux possible
hier soir on s'en est pas rendu compte
mais mme chan a fêté ses attraits
prépare maintenant bon ben on se
retrouve encore entre nous et pour en
profiter un petit peu avec tout le monde
partage et une victoire ça se fait
forcément sur les champs elysées les
joueurs se sont installés sur un bus à
impériale
tout le monde se tient au courant de la
suite des événements avant de remonter
la plus belle avenue du monde
ils l'ont bien mérité bien oui nous nous
sommes avec aimé jacquet et mais on
vient de vous voir sur les
champs-elysées est-ce que ça a été la
plus belle ou la plus longue journée de
votre vis à la plus forte parce que tous
ces gens qui viennent vous remercier qui
sont chaleureux heureux qu'ils échangent
un clin d'oeil ou un petit signe de la
main
c'est parfois je dirais réconfortant ça
nous ça nous ça nous touche profondément
on les voit tout cela derrière vous vous
allez rester amis c'est le terme jusqu'à
jusqu'à demain de votre vie mais je sais
pas si c'est le terme et on a tellement
de complicité on a tellement de temps
passé ensemble on a tellement échanger
on a tellement travaillé on a tellement
souffert on a tellement été ensemble que
cette page que nous venons de tourner
restera à jamais gravé dans nos mémoires
et on n'oublie jamais personne
al'inverse l'équipe brésilienne on la
disait miné de l'intérieur par des clans
et c'est ce que quoique ça ça pousse ça
a pu faire la différence dans ce match
moi j'ai pas senti qu'elle était miné
c'est une équipe qui qui a peut-être pas
pu jouer son bord son meilleur football
qui a ptet pas pu dans ce match de
finale parce que a été redoutable dans
les matches 1 c'est un final peut-être
qu'elle ne s'attendait pas à une équipe
de france aux ti aussi présente aussi
sérieux et aussi performante
je crois que là-dessus nous avons
peut-être réalisé une des plus belles
prestations de notre football
à chaque fois vous nous avez surpris sur
les sept match toutes manières niveau de
france la qualité et puis comme je vous
l'avais dit annoncé ans j'ai utilisé
tous les moyens et tous les toutes les
forces de cette équipe de france je sais
que votre rêve c'est d'emmener la coupe
à sail sous couzan votre village natal
est-ce que vous allez le faire et quand
où et on le fera mais un peu plus tard
parce qu'il est en ce moment j'ai
beaucoup de travail
chose promise chose due une dernière
chose vendredi on connaîtra le nom de
votre successeur à la tête de l'équipe
de france je peux vous demander qui vous
souhaiteriez voir parce que vous
répondriez pas mais vous qu'est ce que
vous allez faire maintenant à moi je
vais retourner à la direction nationale
à la disposition du football de masse et
retrouver mon poste d'entraîneur
national
on prendra plaisir à voir revoir et
merci pour tous ces beaux moments de
bonheur que vous nous avez apporté
merci les politiques se sont bien sûr
mis à l'heure des bleus et de la jacquet
manière à commencer par jacques chirac
leurs plus fervents admirateurs on
l'avait vu en écharpe de supporters au
stade de france cette fois ils étaient
tous footix la mascotte de la coupe du
monde qu'il arborait fièrement sur son
costume un cadeau a dit khatibi de
michel platini leur portage politico
sportif de véronique saint olive et
bruno livertout
on n'avait jamais vu ça l'élysée en
folie
et le président de la république lui
même qui donne le ton
selon lui
et au nom est bon
en mots et en toutes et tous de france
tous les jeunes et je la fais
le plus beau cadeau puisse rêver
l'équipe de france
[Applaudissements]
et qui le pensent et un couple fort
attendu
[Applaudissements]
et c'est la coupe délire jacques chirac
et lionel jospin sont côte à côte la
cohabitation se déchaîne mais c'est le
président de la république qui gère la
situation
[Musique]
le service de nombre est complètement
dépassé jacques chirac se noie dans la
ferveur et dans l' enthousiasme
il sait qu'au delà de la signification
sportive de l'événement
cette communion avec la france toute
entière c'est aussi pain béni pour lui
mais c'est la course aux photos et aux
autographes cette fois les hommes
politiques sont demandeurs le monde à
l'envers
j'ai aimé jacquet chef robert pires
le recul
quand je m'étiole enfin c'est quand même
pas mal
j'aurais donné davantage mais
sur la pelouse toutes étiquettes
confondues on tire déjà les premières
conséquences politiques
je pense que c'est avec la fusion
nationale
avec des chansons entendues
pas de l'ambiance de la confiance en soi
chaque responsable qu'ils soient
politiques qu'ils soient de quelques
situations de la vie publique à
réfléchir sur la façon dont il doit
continuer de porter cette dynamique qui
est des conséquences sont épatantes
parce qu'on a montré qu'en fait la
france était une nation unie sans
distinction entre les années
aujourd'hui personne ne boudait son
plaisir
mais une fois la fête finie yves le
premier ministre et le président de la
république continueront peut de se
marquer voire de ce package
[Musique]
leur dernier passage à l'elysée le 14
juillet dernier a laissé de mauvais
souvenirs aux jardiniers lors de la
traditionnelle garden party la ferveur
autour de l'équipe de france championne
du monde avait pour le moins ravagé la
pelouse du palais national mais bon
prince le locataire des lieux ne leur en
a pas voulu
il les a même convié à nouveau ce matin
pour une très officielle remise de la
légion d'honneur sur place laurent
frédéric bollée et jean corps nu et un
et deux et trois et on ne compte plus
les célébrations la coupe du monde est à
l'elysée et les héros du mondial aussi
ses thèmes et jacquet qui la porte mais
c'est fabien barthez qui est arrivé le
premier
un peu difficile de mettre la cravate
mais l'occasion en vaut évidemment la
peine
c'est un honneur et jeunes donneurs
c'est vrai que c'est un bonheur lewenza
fait c'est sympa c'est cette pâte faire
connaître ici
bah ouais ça troisième fois on n'a pas
non à part peut-être monde
en attendant à l'applaudimètre en tout
cas mention spéciale au double buteur de
la finale
zinédine zidane
je crois que ça montre simplement
pour sortir plusieurs
certains sont venus en famille et
s'apprête à retrouver le premier
supporter des bleus
le président de la république là c'est
facile alors protocole pendant la coupe
du monde était tellement disponible
qu'il avait mis un petit peu de côté le
protocole
finalement ça nous a dérivé d'une
certaine manière puisque il a su nous
mettre à l'aise et finalement lui aussi
contribué à ce qu'on soit dans les
meilleures conditions
ambiance quand même décontracté à
l'intérieur même si ça n'est pas la
garden party du 14 juillet dernier le
président n'a rien oublié et il n'est
sans doute pas le seul
merci les bleus pour ce moment unique
que vous nous avez fait vivre
merci pour ce bonheur immense merci pour
la leçon de tolérance et d'humanité que
vous nous laisser filer des zidane on va
république française
et voilà comment se termine une grande
et belle aventure cette semaine après la
finale face au brésil la france est
fière de ses champions du monde
le foot ça mène à tout même à la légion
d'honneur
[Musique]